sponsored by step finance your
go to d5 portfolio manager
on solana luno if you're just getting into
bitcoin it's the perfect place to start
hey guys and welcome back to the late highlander
fan show the reason i'm smiling from it right now
is because that's a new intro and i think that was
really cool you can let me know if you like it um
so today's gonna be really interesting we're
talking about bitcoin mining um i think it's a
pretty hot topic given everything that's going on
in the world um but before we delve into this this
particular episode actually all of these episodes
um are powered by icon plus capital so they're a
vc firm so definitely go check them out and it's
also sponsored by blockfy who offer really great
interest rates um especially on stable coins so i
use them i love them so definitely go check that
out so like i said today we are talking about
bitcoin mining now i am joined with somebody
who um was kind of on the front page of the
daily mail and there was a really clickbaity
headline um so we're going to find out how
accurate this is but this is the headline
jp barrick dropped out of college and turned 1400
investment into 1.3 million dollars in a month
through bitcoin mining jp is that true welcome to
the show is it true well i did drop out of college
i did start with a small amount of money
i used to run at like a robotics camp when
i was in high school and used that money to buy
cryptocurrency in 2013 and beyond and i did end up
making over a million dollars i wouldn't directly
correlate it and i didn't do it in a month but
uh yes some of those things are true the media
loves to take the story and make it you know the
headline even though you know they take things
out of context but at the end of the day bitcoin
mining has brought me wealth that's amazing yeah
i mean it's always taken out of context but i'm
so excited to go into this with you because we
were still talking backstage and i think that
right now mining is super hot just because it
is so affected by the geopolitical landscape but
before we do delve into that can you just tell
us you know about your background what you do
um just so people know you know why you're
basically the expert to talk about this
yeah so i got into the mining space in 2016 got
into bitcoin in 2013 when i was in high school
uh went to college for computer science dropped
out of school to start the company called mining
store and mining store has been focused on
bringing bitcoin and cryptocurrency mining to
retail and institutional investors across the
space and basically making the mining space
more accessible um and i i was the original
question i got into this because of what
yeah no no no well the question was
who are you but that that's not true
mining store no well tell us what's mining store
just so people can finally yeah so so mining store
is a white glove solutions to get into bitcoin
mining people who have no idea how to get into
mining or have really don't want to have to deal
with power bills don't have to deal with hosting
contracts don't have to deal with replacement
parts and mining store provides all those
services and then in addition we're working with
influencers to launch their own mining companies
and make mining more accessible by dropping the
price of getting into bitcoin mining from ten
thousand dollars or nine thousand dollars to buy
one miner to actually like a hundred dollars now
so we're trying to make it super accessible and
available so anyone can invest in in a mining
operation okay so we're going to talk about
that because i want to start mining because
i unfortunately don't so we're going to get into
that um but how did you then hear about mining
backdoors in 2017 like how did you do that in
college so in 2016 i was a senior in high school
and i was into crypto i had my own mining rig in
my parents basement you know just gpu rigs i ended
up buying some butterfly labs miners that took
forever to get shipped they were like some of the
first asics built here in the united states and
then um i raised about a hundred thousand dollars
from family and friends for my grandparents put
up some money myself uh from my own money yeah
especially as you know someone who was 17 years
old maybe 18 years old somewhere in that range so
uh i took that capital i bought 300 graphics cards
started mining in a old um kind of like area where
they made coats and made um clothing and in graham
north carolina and then that's where the mining
store started was just a shopify store we actually
were selling the equipment we were building custom
rigs for people and shipping it to them the
problem is when they arrived at the site of
this other individual that bought it on ebay they
were just so broken the mail just destroyed them
every time and so we kind of learned like what
we could and couldn't do and how we could sell
miners online more effectively and from there i've
just been iterating on the process to now where
you know we're dropping the barrier of entry
and using new uh new regulatory frameworks in
order to in order to do that but how did you know
what you're doing because it's so early i mean
even raising a hundred thousand dollars is wild
i mean for me i've always been an entrepreneur
so i mentioned the lego robotics camp before uh my
dad when i was younger he was like if you want to
go to a summer camp you have to pay for half of it
and so let's go sell strawberries to our neighbors
and so we walked around to the neighbors and said
hey do you want to buy strawberries i'm going to
go pick them and so my dad just kind of helped me
grow and be an entrepreneur and also gave me the
i guess the confidence to believe that you can do
whatever you put your mind to and that you have
the ability to you know to grow a business and
you have the ability to make money and it's not
something that's only reserved for people that are
educated and in my you know my sense i was only in
high school and since then i've learned a lot by
a b testing and then by running a company just by
doing it i think that's such um an important life
lesson um you know that it's just sort of what
your parents instill in you um because so many
people sort of have this mindset that you have
to come from you know endless amounts of money to
be so called privileged but i really think that
having good parents that instill um a really
healthy work ethic in you um and also just like
not just work ethic but like mentality within
you is the most privileged thing you could have
100 agree the mentality that i was able to receive
from my parents and the support when it was like
okay this is how you get insurance like my dad was
like hey here's my insurance broker um that i use
and i you know i was like 16 17 trying to figure
out how to get insurance so this is you know it's
a process and you learn and throughout that whole
experience i was able to hire people i was able to
hire my friends fire all my friends hire people
that got paid a hundred thousand dollars a year
and thought that was like the biggest expense ever
you know rent a building and having to pay for the
rent of my building for the whole year up front
because they were like there's no way we're gonna
rent this to you i was like well what happens i
pay for it all now they're like okay we'll run
it to you so like getting through uh those stages
and be able to meet great people and connect with
great people in the community and still like today
to be able to say like hey i know that person
when i see them in public like we still recognize
each other we still talk and chat which is
it's an amazing feeling and so it's not you're
not you're on this journey by yourself you're
on this journey with the community and you're
here i believe we're all here to build you know
the future of the world and future finance just
briefly how was it hiring and firing your friends
well i hired all my friends in 2017 with mining
stores it was like six guys in a room doing phone
calls you know it was great we were making money
but then like things started getting bad and
bitcoin mining became unprofitable and bitcoin
started crashing and so my friends like i had to
let them all go eventually at some point and they
uh i've learned a lot since then but i learned
that like you don't want to hire your friends uh
because they're friends they're not working people
they're not your business partners it's better
to go out in the in the environment and find
the right people fit for the job versus just like
you know hey we're going to all jump on this boat
together and see where we go yeah i totally agree
with you pleasure in business keep them separate
um so the whole idea is to make mining accessible
for the average person essentially is that correct
that's correct will world-class mining facilities
make mining accessible for everyone so how do
you do that so that's the question i you know
i've been asking myself for for for years now
and like we've thought about nfts i we've thought
about um other routes where um you could like buy
a portion of a bitcoin miner and have it run for
you but what we realized at the end of the day was
there is a really cool new regulation out there
called regulation crowdfunding and so we launched
a product called bitvault which allows for any
influencer to start their own mining company
and we uh mining store provide the services
required to come keep those miners running
keep them operational and the influencer basically
makes content about it similar to like a sponsor
and they end up owning about twenty percent of
the company so the influencer and ourselves own
twenty 20 and we sell 80 of it to the fans so the
fans put in their dollars you take an 80 20 split
similar to a hedge fund and you're able to raise
up to 5 million dollars legally in the united
states from on from unregistered investors or
unaccredited investors so this means we can take
100 investments from anyone not only us citizens
but anyone in the world and you don't even need to
be a us citizen to launch one you can be you know
a uk citizen and you can launch a reg cf still
so we're super excited to bring bitcoin mining
to the communities of all these influencers
and to allow anyone to get into mining because
we all know that eight thousand dollars is way
too expensive for most of the population yeah it
really is um but then that sort of brings me on
to like my next question which i often hear about
um is the idea that you know it's difficult to do
it on your own so you end up getting these large
mining pools um and then they become centralized
um so are there any concerns there how do we
tackle that what would your response be to that
yeah so the mining pools um the first
pool ever came out was slush pool
and they existed because they the network
was getting too hard as you mentioned
so what we're focused on um or what the mining
industry is focused on is getting steady payouts
so mining pools are necessary to provide steady
payouts to smaller miners anyone who has less
than 25 megawatts is probably doing a pool mining
and 25 megawatts is hundreds of millions like 100
million dollars worth of equipment today if it's
all new generation so it's very very expensive
you're not going to be able to not join a pool if
you're a consumer um regarding the centralization
of pools i think that was definitely a problem
more in 2017 um today we have a lot of pools a
lot of great pool operators and a lot of people
um optimizing and innovating in the pool space
in the future i don't think when i saw you need
mining pools i think that mining pools are going
to be like become a layer two solution and will be
built into some like blockchains or other software
protocols um and they'll be decentralized
but we're getting there yeah and i think that
right now mining is at this really awkward stage
because we've had well in the us you you know you
had the infrastructure bill where you didn't have
sort of that clarification on you know the time
what's a broker um and then you've also
you've got like this increased regulation
and then you've also got the fact that
like everything geopolitically is such
a mess whether it's you know china whether it's
you know people moving from miners moving from
china to kazakhstan and the internet getting
shut down in kazakhstan because of a protest
and then miners setting up in ukraine and then
everything going on so we did see you know the
china shutdown of course obviously affect the
hash rate there was a recovery but the price
obviously still took a hit so how are you
navigating that right now just the initial kind of
helping people set up shop and also just knowing
where to set up shop so with bitcoin mining it's
the only real thing on the bitcoin blockchain that
physica that has a physical existence in the real
world like nodes yes they do exist but they're
very easy to run you'll run them on a server
there's plenty of servers all over the world and
people don't have an issue getting access to them
when it comes to the mining servers there are no
operations like them they're deploying thousands
of them it's a ton of power in a concentrated
area and you brought up the geopolitical risk for
ourselves we focus on the united states we've
looked at we've looked at doing projects in
ukraine at nuclear power plants we've looked
at doing projects in in uganda in nigeria
in south in brazil in canada we've always stuck
to the us because of the amount of abundant clean
energy we have here so the united states is one
of the biggest um developers of clean energy and
is pouring the most amount of capital out of most
countries into clean energy so we have all of this
clean energy going in texas and in the midwest
and that energy actually can't get to anyone uh
because we're building it away from population
centers so that provides a great opportunity for
bitcoin miners to come in and to arbitrage that
energy and to sell it to the bitcoin network and
buy it for pennies on the dollar literally two
cents three cents per kilowatt hour so when it
comes to geopolitical risk we haven't gone into
those other countries due to those issues because
um financiers insurance companies they all like
the us much better as a as a regime to you know
trust and we're seeing that the us is respecting
mining and it's also very hard for the us to do a
blanket ban of mining like another country could
because of the different regulations regarding
power usage and the different regulatory bodies
and state local and federal that regulate how
the grid operates and how what type of energy
you can use and how energy consumption works
but obviously i mean just from an entrepreneurial
standpoint i imagine that eventually you would
like to go global is that right so going global to
me looks like going global on the software level
right so yeah yeah i i would love to build you
know we're working out how do we build large
power plants in these other countries but at
the end of the day like the majority of mining
machines um will be running at one site and you
can fit for example an 80 megawatt site we can
fit 23 000 servers there that 20 those 23 000
servers at 100 a piece those could be owned by
let's say 2.3 million people all across the world
yes so that's the goal is to scale with software
and keep the infrastructure in the us in places
where we know for a fact that the representations
we're making online we're going to be able
to follow through over the five year period
in terms of you know these bands that we're
seeing globally just outside of you know
your infrastructure and everything that you're
building how do you feel that that is going to
affect the network because we obviously saw what
happened with china um i know i know obviously
the price recovered and so did the hash
rate but you know it did take some time
and then the same you know it's concerning about
the miners in russia and kazakhstan and i think
i also actually know sorry ukraine um and i
think i also read again i don't quote me on
this because i can't remember exactly what it
was but i think i read that they're shutting
off access to the internet outside of russia so
they're only going to be so they're only going
to have access to russian internet but even
a vpn won't be enough to get around that so
you know how how does that affect the network i
mean i have no idea how the russian miners are
gonna pull that one off and get and figure out
how to do it obviously uh there's the internet
and then there's uh other layers of communication
i don't know if the bitcoin nodes can communicate
without the internet um on their own protocol so
i'm i know they use the internet as a backbone but
i'm unsure how that's gonna affect uh the port
you know i think the port that all the nodes
are on uh from transmitting information and then
exactly exactly right affect the stratum server
or the servers connecting to the mining pools
um we'll see i think they have five days that's
what i heard yesterday i was like damn five
days to make a whole new internet out here
um and i hope that you know i hope that the
miners who put up the money who invested
infrastructure right you know this is this isn't
just like building a website where you can move
it to another server you're putting out exactly
millions of dollars of physical hardware you're
putting up millions of dollars of labor electoral
components so these are real people's livelihoods
that could be you know in jeopardy uh because
of this these bitcoin mining slash internet
bans that are occurring in russia yeah i mean does
it concern you that you know you've you've chosen
the us because you feel that it is you know a safe
place um you know it's somewhat stable kind of um
does it concern you that mining could become
centralized and in the us you know the same
way we used to have those kind of accusations
about china i think that it concerns me if
there's any one country that has more control
of 50 of the hash rate and could dictate um
a you know some sort of protocol change or did
not necessarily protocol change but dictate uh
blocks reorgs or something that the miners would
have to comply with to approve transactions and
only us-based blocks so i i like decentralization
and i think that we're going to be continuing to
build decentralization layers on the pool level
and if that starts to happen then as a minor
you'll be able to connect to a pool where
they have no idea where you're coming from
um but at the end of the day we all have uh
legislators and regulatory bodies we have to
you know listen to and uh not not avoid but like
follow the regulations they put out and we want
to have productive conversations with them at the
end of the day we're here to challenge how energy
consumption and the energy discussion is handled
in the united states uh mining store one of our
goals is to frame the energy conversation
of bitcoin energy is energy well spent
so you're when you're using on bitcoin mining it's
not like you're going to going to waste when we
talk we don't talk about how much energy we're
using when we're traveling on a plane or when
we're driving to work or when we watch netflix
no we don't have that conversation because it
doesn't it doesn't have a direct correlation
bitcoin mining has been selected as the energy
behemoth and like taking up all the world's power
but the reality is it's very small like if if you
look at the concrete production and how much co2
that emits and how much energy concrete production
uses we're not saying we shouldn't build roads
anymore because it's too bad for the environment
you know we're continuing to do that
and continue to expand our society
yeah i think there are two points there it's well
it's the whole idea that like bitcoin mining is a
net positive for the environment i think that's
sort of how satoshi put it um that it's a net
positive so i do just want to actually break down
the whole energy consumption issue because i know
there's still a lot of people some people really
watching don't really understand it you know we
do see those major headlines um which say you know
even even across europe actually at the moment you
know they're talking about potentially banning and
proof of work because it's bad for the environment
so can you break down for us you know why it's
not as bad as they say and why is the net positive
so bitcoin mining is a net positive for the energy
usage because of i would say three trends um the
first one is the the the amount of energy that
is consumed by consumers and the community is
different for every hour of the day so in the
morning and in the evenings as humans we all
do two things and we we wake up we make coffee
and that actually that like energy usage plus
the heat heat going on across all the us in the
world uh creates a energy usage like resurgence
so people need energy but the energy production
has to match that energy consumption every single
day every single hour every single minute unless
the grid could fail and so what bitcoin miners
do is they help um alleviate the peaks and
valleys so the peak would be when everyone's
using energy in the morning or the evening and
the valleys would be during the day when we're
not necessarily using as much energy so bitcoin
miners by adding more consumption to the grid
allow a utility to say instead of having to
turn on let's say 10 megawatts of coal plants
to give energy to the community we can simply
tell this bitcoin miner like we do in iowa
to turn off their mining facility for that set
two hours during the day during the months where
we really need it and we can have them give the
energy back to the people so bitcoin miners allow
more renewable energy production because renewable
energy production is not um it's not consistent
it's variable and so that means you can't turn it
on and off like you can with coal and natural gas
which is how we meet those demands to currently so
by being able to build more renewable energy we're
able to um we're able to effectively ensure that
the amount of energy consumed by consumers that is
renewable energy is a higher percentage because
now there's a large consumer of that energy and
then when that renewable energy is available and
the grid needs it back the bitcoin miner turns
off because they're financially incentivized to
based on the power rate so the power contract is
set up for this to happen now that right
there is why bitcoin miners and how they
play into the electric grid and and why they're
beneficial and not necessarily a bad thing because
they allow us to build more renewable energy
production that's variable which then in return
allows everyone to win including the community
and do you find yourself having to sort of
explain the difference between you know how
much energy is wasted or used compared to with
bitcoin compared to the traditional financial
system i mean do you know the stats off the top
of your head i know that i don't okay i i know
i know that i know that the traditional system
and even gold the whole entire production of
gold is just so much more um than bitcoin um
well i wanna that's i think i still think you're
comparing right so when you're when you start
fighting that argument you start playing like
we're gonna compare us to real estate to gold what
we're really saying is energy usage is bad you're
still playing into their argument that energy use
is bad but they're we're better than that yeah so
the goal is not to compare energy usage at all to
anyone the goal is to say energy usage is actually
a net positive for society and using energy can
can allow us to become more productive can bring
more people out of poverty and can provide more
jobs and economic freedom and increase gdp so
they've seen and there's some great articles by
nick carter on this that as a country uses more
energy they have a lower death rate they have a
lower uh a birth rate when it comes to deaths
during you know childbirth they have a better
um lifestyle they have a longer age of living
so that's one thing then when in addition
there's something called the energy value that's
energy with an m and energy value is the unit of
calculation of how much energy went into an asset
to create it so that one of the highest energy
value assets is steel and steel is very valuable
to society and that's why it's valuable is because
you put a lot of energy into it and now people are
building a building with it because it's so strong
so the same thing goes with bitcoin bitcoin will
has a high energy value because we're putting
tons of energy into the asset itself which then
in return makes it more valuable to society so
i see bitcoin mining as that positive feedback
loop that helps ensure that every four years the
padding happens bitcoins become harder to get they
require double the amount of energy to acquire
which then pushes the price up and provides more
more jobs more megawatts to be deployed and more
mining machines working in the mines so i think
that bitcoin's energy usage we shouldn't compare
to other industries instead we should say as a
society we should be proud of the energy we use we
should be proud of how much energy we're using and
we want to use it in an environmentally friendly
way yeah i understand i think that the reason
people tend to do that though is just because
there's like this double standard and there's
this kind of concern that there's an ulterior
motive going on i mean there seems to be such
a lack of nuance um especially in the states
with the politicians when it comes
to talking about bitcoin mining so
i wonder if you have any opinion on you know
why there's a lack of nuance do you think
it's just because they don't understand
or do you think you know it's because
having that nuance and you know having a bitcoin
for any environment poses a threat to the us
dollar and then they don't want that yeah i think
bitcoin you know is the first thing to say hey we
can do money without you as a state uh that's why
you know in 2013 i became interested in in it when
i was in high school it's for that one reason i
didn't need to ask anyone permission i could get
on get on the bitcoin network i could buy bitcoin
and i could uh you know transact without having to
be uh 15 years old i could you know do as a young
person so for me when it comes to bitcoin mining
and how the energy debate is being framed i think
it's important that um we understand that energy
creation and manufacturing which is what bitcoin
mining is where manufacturing new bitcoin is
viewed as a net positive across the world and
across the united states they communities want
manufacturing jobs they love it they want they
want jobs they want energy usage they want to
build their community when you tell them we're
manufacturing bitcoin they're like wait what
there's no product there but that doesn't mean
they don't want it when you when you talk about
data centers coming in and building a data center
everyone says yes we want our data center yes we
want it it doesn't matter that it's using energy
it doesn't matter they have not that many jobs
we need the data centers and so with bitcoin
mining i think the politicians can't say yes it's
a good thing because this is one of their key this
will be one of their key uh i guess points that
why we should regulate bitcoin and why bitcoin's
bad is because it uses energy and that's why i'm
saying that debate is we need to reframe it of
like energy usage isn't inherently bad bitcoin
mining uses energy but it also helps produce more
renewable energy and allow the grid to be more
reliable more sustainable and more dynamic without
that you don't have a grid that works grids have
to meet consumption and production 24 7 and you
need a lot of both in order to match it up with
renewable energy that's um you know variable
can you delve into the whole energy arbitrage
thing because i think that is the most interesting
part because this is the first because this is the
first time we're seeing energy decentralized right
yeah effectively bitcoin mining is a the global
buyer of energy so anywhere in the world you can
export these electrons through the bitcoin mining
computers which turn the electrons into heat
that's the only output there's no radioactive
material nothing comes out of it that's bad
there's only heat the heat gets exhausted and
the what happens when you're creating that heat
is the computers are doing a math problem that
math problem in return gets rewarded bitcoins uh
from the pool for contributing their work to the
pool or to the bitcoin network and that process
right there is effectively taking electricity
that's stranded that's in the midwest that's has
nowhere to go we're looking at uh some wind farms
and a few of them generate energy and 75 percent
of the time they're putting energy in the ground
because they can't actually get it on the
transmission line the transmission line's already
full no one needs it but that project that i'm
talking about has been there for 12 13 years and
so it's already paid off the investor's already
done now it's like we're gonna you know dismantle
it or we don't need it anymore and so the fact is
is that there's plenty of energy the problem is
energy is not in the right spot because it's hard
to transmit energy we have less transmission lines
here in the united states because it's
if we incentivize energy production
with like green energy credits and wrecks and um
but we don't incentivize transmission of energy
or consumption of energy you know you don't get
paid to consume energy what happens if you did
well as a bitcoin miner you do get paid to
use energy and you're selling that energy
to the bitcoin network and that's the one paying
you so bitcoin provides this um almost like what i
would call like basic um wealth or universal basic
income to anyone who wants to plug a computer in
and wants to arbitrage energy and so with mining
store we're working on getting the lowest cost
energy so that the people on our platform can
arbitrage the energy at two or three cents to
the to the bitcoin network and make you know and
sell for 25 cents 30 cents 40 cents whatever the
bitcoin price is and get that arbitrage all day
long and never have to actually go to the facility
and work and plug in the machines and deal with
the noise we don't we don't want that we just
want them to say okay get on a 100 level be able
to quickly get an allocation to the space and do
it through software because that's the future
of bitcoin mining as we see it for consumers
yeah i really want to do this i have to get
involved um when i think about a year ago elon
musk was it a year ago no nearly it was about may
last year or maybe even april to be honest elon
musk made that whole u-turn with tesla because
of his environmental concerns how um how genuine
do you think his environmental concerns were i
think elon's a very smart guy um as you saw with
his cree even he's like we need to ramp up natural
gas and oil production in the u.s i can't believe
i'm saying this but um the thing is is elon has
people who he needs to you know keep his friends
and when you're getting hundreds of millions and
billions of dollars of tax credits and um and
you know renewable energy advocates and battery
storage credits and all the the tax advantages
he's getting the the face of only clean energy
that elon puts on you know he has to maintain it
and with bitcoin mining i think he got a knock
on the door from someone and said hey you can't
you can't be saying this like you guys bought
bitcoin that was already enough now you're
coming out and saying bitcoin is good that
doesn't fit our agenda that's my personal
opinion and i think he knows the fact that as a
society we need to use more energy and he's heard
of those theories and that he understands
that he wants to make it more clean energy
and bitcoin mining is one way to increase
adoption of clean energy and grid reliability
yeah it's interesting i tend to think that he i
think it was just a mistake like i cuz i i feel
like okay i could be totally wrong but i feel i
feel he's a bit i do think he's kind of honest
um you know i don't think he's one of those shady
characters i mean you never really know do you
um but i tend to think he's more of an honest
one um and i feel it was just a mistake
he didn't really understand it it's why it took
him so long to get involved um you know i i think
it was just a mistake i'm not really sure um
but it is interesting and you know where do you
where do you then see this going over the next 10
years um you know i feel like we're in the middle
of this battle right now um you know climate
change their narrative around climate change is
certainly heating up um you know to what extent do
you think bitcoin's going to take the brunt of it
to what extent do i think bitcoin is going to
take the brunt of what again of this climate
change narrative that's heating up i think i
mean bitcoin will be in front and center in the
climate change debate as we just continue to move
forward and as society progresses because it uses
so much energy and i think bitcoin what we're
seeing now is it's actually becoming a feature
to the energy companies so the energy companies
who own the energy assets are looking to build
bitcoin mines at their facilities when they
can't sell their power to the grid and so now
the end of the the big players are coming in per
se like right now it's been the small guys and
it's been if you didn't have really cheap energy
it was hard to compete but now that bitcoin is
where it's at and the price point it's been stable
the market is changing the market has a problem
where there's too much production and not enough
consumption i think the market will dictate um
the bitcoin mining like deployments in the us
regarding the policy discussion and the news cycle
i i we've seen bitcoin mining you know
be pronounced dead hundreds of times
i think we're going to see bitcoin mining
energy usage be continued to be debated
and there has to be more research and more
community effort to bring awareness to energy
usage being an inherently good thing and not bad
yeah i think el salvador is obviously this kind of
experiment slash shining light slash something
something that's going on right now um you know
it isn't it is an experiment and it is like some
shining light when it comes to you know innovation
um so the volcanoes are really interesting
have you had a chance to check them out yet
i i have never been to the volcanoes but i have
had conversations with parties who are mining
crypto in el salvador uh we consult
with a few groups down there
um and we you know we are reviewing geothermal
as an energy source and how in you know how to
drill geothermal wells to generate clean energy
as i see it's one of the best ways to generate uh
renewable energy that's 24 7. and so i think its
applications for bitcoin mining are tremendous
do you think like the us is ever going to do
something similar you know the way they've built
what they've built you know with the government
backing um you know it's just so crazy well
the us i think takes the position of let's
let the private companies generate the energy
and uh sell them to the grid and in in the energy
companies their goal is not to uh to get the rate
the consumer pays to be lower the goal of energy
companies to get more assets on their balance
sheet to pay bigger debts and interest so that
their consumer the person who's buying the power
has to pay uh for those fees so that they can get
more assets on the utilities balance sheet so at
the end of the day we are making geothermal energy
in the united states we are there's plants that do
it in california um and i don't i see that we need
more clean energy throughout the world and we need
more nuclear we need more geothermal and i realize
even things like hydro you consider that renewable
energy but that has um a ton of this this the
water that's stable and it's like stale actually
causes like co2 emissions and has uh you know
biogas and uh different types of issues with it so
um i think the geothermal and nuclear path
are a great way for us to deploy a lot of
energy but it's not what we're looking at
we're looking at solar and wind because it's
um being subsidized by the government where
geothermal is not i'm with you um you're
also the founder of rm capital ventures am i even
pronouncing that correctly that's correct so tell
tell me about that where does that fit into
everything yeah so that's the parent company
that we have that owns uh every different llc
we have so we're in the mining space we're also
in the helium space we're launching a helium
um a minor which is the people's internet um
we are in um we're in the consulting space we
have different product lines we're in the software
space so we separate each one of our companies
out underneath it and build brands for like the
mining store and for bit vault based on what the
consumer or who the audience is and orem capital
ventures is the parent company which we receive
investment into and which our employees gain
shares from or you know get get option contracts
and kind of invest into and get ownership in it so
what's the overall goal for you because you
obviously you know you started this in 2017 which
actually somebody tweeted uh today saying 2017
is five years ago which is actually insane
that's five years ago so it's time time is getting
on so what's you know the next big thing are you
just going to be dedicating your career and your
life to mining or are you looking at anything else
are you interested in proof of stake you know so i
like steak but not proof of steak um i'm dedicated
i'm dedicating my you know my resources and
time and talent to making bitcoin mining more
accessible to everyone so anyone can get into
this space making bitcoin mining um cheaper
for the energy so working on figuring out what's
the best energy mix how do i get the lowest cost
energy and i love the energy space i love building
massive buildings i love construction and i love
software because i was a computer science major in
school and i'm realizing that to make an impact on
the world you need to you know have a radical idea
and for me that radical idea is energy usage is a
good thing and let's incentivize energy usage flip
the argument on its head and let's show off you
know how much energy layla and her bitcoin miners
and her whole community is using and let's have
her compete with you know natalie or with josh
terry or with mr beast who had a bitcoin mine
so there's all these influencers who have mined
bitcoin in the past they might not have told you
about it or they're currently mining crypto
and we want to make it a public thing that
we share like a social media for influencers to
focus on finances and raising money through the
regulated crowdfunding framework i think that
framework is going to change how we sell our
time so you know most people sell their time for
money i think in the future we should sell our
time for equity and i think everyone should have
a regulated crowdfund that they own and they can
create content about an industry and get their
fans to put money into it to be owners with them
and they get to build really cool things uh with
their fans so that's what i'm excited for when
i'm eager to build and you know the journey is
just starting um in the software space for us
and it's also interesting because you know
you have to have a huge you know desire for
decentralization and love for decentralization in
order to sort of you know devote a career and to
build everything that you're building so i'd like
to understand where that interest comes from you
know what what is it about decentralization
what is it about bitcoin for you um you know
that has allowed you to dedicate so much time
energy and you know all these resources to it
so what i would say for me is that underlying
um belief that you know money is by the people
for the people and money should work for you and
not against you when i make the decision to hold
us dollars in my bank account or to transact in
u.s dollars i'm effectively saying that the you
know i'm using money that is depreciating
in value when i'm using bitcoin i'm using
money that is the the best store of value in the
world that you know was recreated with tons of
energy and that is inherently valuable that's
the belief that keeps me going all day long
the belief that no one should be able to tell
you based on your race your age your religion
if you can or can't do a transaction i think that
we all should have that should be a god-given
right and that's what i'm looking to build on top
of which is not only should we receive be able to
use these networks we show these networks work for
us and bitcoin mining put out 25 billion dollars
last year in mining revenue and we want to get
that into the people's hands we want to get as
many consumers mining bitcoin at an at a hundred
dollar price point and becoming um you know
opening up that gate of wealth creating uh freedom
for those individuals showing them that you can
create money through the bitcoin mining process
and you can come out at the end of the day
with more bitcoin than you had uh you know getting
into the investment or mining without with you
know without starting mining that's that's the
end goal the end goal is to give people that
flexibility freedom that i got to experience and i
get to experience in my life because i was able to
be on this technol technological trend you know
earlier than most the thing is you got into in
2016-17 so you must have been around 18 or 19.
so i got into crypto 2013 but then mining 2016.
okay so well okay wow that's even younger how
old are you in 2013. i think we're a similar
age i was like 14. i'm 24 now oh okay you
you're you weren't 14 in 2013. i was older 15
14 right 15. i'm 24 now 15 and 20 yeah 20 22. oh
my god okay right so i was 15 years old over here
and that's okay 15 15. yeah yeah loving crypto
yeah but so but the thing is it must have been
it must have been the tech like that's why you
got into it right yeah i mean i was so i in high
school i was taking like macro and microeconomic
classes and i like loved that and i was like
byzantine generals theory like why does bitcoin
work and i was the kid i went to a small high
school 50 people per class and i was the kid who
just told everyone about bitcoin got my teachers
into it and now it's the running joke like when i
go back to speak at schools they're like oh my god
like we should have bought bitcoin and then same
thing in college like that's just who i've been
because i'm obsessed with the technology and also
i'm weird enough where i'll state my facts and
opinions and be like i don't have to be the normal
one i don't have to believe what everyone else is
believing and i'll be the guy that's like hey you
should buy bitcoin at 70 a coin to my family and
now i'm the same guy here pitching the same stuff
it's because i truly believe with my heart that
bitcoin is the best thing for the world when it
comes to money and it's the best money for the
world it's freedom and so that's why i'm working
on building products that kind of let people get
out of that nine-to-five job let them get out of
that confused state where they're barely making
it by my goal is to build wealth for society and
i want to do build wealth through clean energy and
bitcoin mining which are both massive industrial
processes infrastructure builds wealth and
there's plenty of good research on showing that
infrastructure builds society and builds gdp and i
think bitcoin mining clean energy has the ability
to do that for communities across the globe
but when did you my question is like when did you
have that realization because you you were the
guy that was in it for the tech right and now you
end up with the freedom and i do i think there's
a difference there for me i think i started with
the freedom right so the reason why no you started
with the tech you were like the nerdy kid you
were just saying that was telling your teachers
to buy it for 70 cents yeah well so i'm telling
them to buy for 70 but why am i interested in it
i'm interested in it because no one can tell
me what i can't find can he can't do which is
but how do you have that realization at 15 you
read wikipedia and you realize that like i mean
for me like i'm trying to think back then i there
was no issues back when we were 15 we're like a
similar age there were no issues when we were 15.
i remember when i was 15 thinking the world was so
easy people told you you couldn't do something and
i didn't like that i was defying that like as a
since a young kid i've always defined defied like
societal standards of like what's okay with school
and like what do you have an example like what
for example like the first day of high school the
first second day of high school or second year
of high school i they had a rule book i went to
an early college so we could leave the college
campus and they if we didn't have class and so
i read both the rule books and i was like here's
the rules you guys just put it out we just all
signed it here's the other rules therefore i don't
have a class i'm not going to be counted absent so
i'm going to leave it's like that was my mentality
as a sophomore in high school and like in middle
school i was you know always trying to figure out
how to how to build this next thing like starting
robotics camp i'm always trying to to basically
innovate and build value for people because at
a young age i had this this this like there's not
discernment but this vision of like hey you need
to uh pay for your own [ __ ] like you need to
you need to create value in the world for my dad
and so as a 15 year old i'm trying to solve my
financial problems and then i've realized like
okay how do you do that effectively well i'm
not going to sell my time i'm going to build
businesses and so that believe in that structure
being a business owner i've never had guard rails
right i dropped out of school so like we had
the guardrails i was like i don't want to do
this anymore i'm done same thing with business
like you have the guardrails but in the business
the gargoyles are really really broad and you can
play in that space so i've always been someone to
play in that arena because i believe that you know
bitcoin is a life-changing technology because it
is a free it's freedom freedom for the world
freedom for everyone and it's the the protocol
you know the trust protocol as we would call it or
as mark usko would say selling um not selling time
for dollars is um it sounds really obvious but
i definitely think it's like an advanced sort of
mentality that not the average person um is sort
of aware of so did your dad teach you that or is
that something you've read or you came across
or realized on your own it's something that i
i think i believe i developed it like i read the
four hour work week over time i was always trying
to create value by that being an arbitrage like
by selling the strawberries or by robotics camp
the way i positioned that in my brain was like
okay if i can get a hot 10 kids at 15 an hour
or ten dollars an hour that's 150 or 50 you know
15 kids at 15 an hour like that's going to be um
more effective than me working at 12 hour dollars
an hour at a job so like that's when i started
comparing like okay i can get 10x my revenue here
and then eventually you're like okay i won't sell
my time for money at all i'm only interested in
building equity and that's what i want to help
the world get to is that belief that they want
to be an owner in their company they want to
sell equity and selling your time for dollars
is secure it gives you that sense of security
but it doesn't give you that it's fake it's
fake right it's not it's not real so why do
you do what you do today i'm curious now to hear
me yourself oh god what's the question so why are
you in crypto and what are your beliefs behind it
oh well i'm a die-hard freedom maximalist don't
tell me what to do i'm competent on my own i don't
need the daddy government to tell me what to do um
look like i think i think that um humans can truly
prosper um once they're left to prosper on their
own right like it's kind of like a we're like
plants um and you know if you keep if you keep
like over over nurturing the plant and you keep
doing too much to it i think it will die if you
just give it you know the correct environment um i
think it can flourish and be very beautiful um and
i really believe in like personal responsibility
and that's what i love about bitcoin um because so
i i've kind of like taken bitcoin to the extreme
so like you know the whole idea of like don't um
don't trust verify i now like double check
everything in my life you know everything you know
have have a backup plan be you know really verify
don't trust that that's gonna work out so i just i
just sort of feel we should um you know empower
people to take personal responsibility i think
that um you know governments are too uh act like
a nanny state too much and i think that that um
i think that that disempowers people um so and
was that yeah created by society or your parents
like how did you come up with that belief as well
that's a great question um i know what seemed like
me i'm sorry i'm very sorry i'm really sorry um i
think that well firstly my i have an older brother
he's two years older than me and he definitely
sort of red peeled me if you like um but just
overall i think that um you know i sort of just
seen that things aren't going to be handed to you
um and you have to just sort of you can get
anything you want as long as as long as you
create it um and you know as well like if you rely
on the government you're only going to get x far
but if you rely on yourself you'll get much
further because you have all the control
like you have all the control over everything
so you really can pull as many strings as you
like right you can call the shots and you can
create as much as you want if you have to rely
on a government or something like that then
you're you're kind of you're stuck in a box
and then also i think like governments are corrupt
and so on and so on but anyway this like i don't
know talk all about me okay that this so this is
theory called i watched a documentary called hyper
normalization and the fact the belief is is like
we are currently know the system is broken like
society is realizing today especially with the war
that the system is breaking is broken and we're
all just acting like everything's okay and we
all are aware that everyone else has no idea what
they're doing everyone else is acting and there's
this thing called inflation that just keeps on
uh digging away at everything we're trying to
buy and making it more expensive so the people
are going to continue to wake up because their
standard of living is getting crushed right now
and they're going to be asking for where is a
monetary supply that i can put my capital into
that is different than this fake money that we're
all believing exists and the prices keep going up
every day with the internet with the how fast tick
tock and instagram can push uh media and news i
see an advent where now we have an opportunity
to opt out and it's plan b it's bitcoin
yeah it's really exciting and i think that um
right now we're in this really weird kind of
push and pull phase um because like you know
there's so much to bitcoin and it's not just
you know opting out like there is this kind of
entrepreneurial side of it just because it does
require you to take personal responsibility um
you know over over your keys over your finances
it's just a mentality but the the other side of
the coin is that we also live in a world where
some people just i mean i don't know if this is
true but i'm just gonna sort of say it some people
just sort of aren't built that way um you know
some people prefer security some people prefer
uh we all prefer security um okay yes but
we but we but what we what we perceive as
secure is different right like you and i would
think that nine to five is really dangerous
yeah i would agree with that but we all have
these natural rights that we're looking to
uh ensure and you know for me that's that's that's
cash flow for for anyone that's cash flow that's
ensuring that they have uh something set away for
the future and that they know they're not gonna
have to work their their whole life um the thing
the thing about bitcoin is that you know with
the internet anyone can access these beliefs now
and we can express these beliefs like we are today
and before that the information just
didn't get out as fast and now with bitcoin
you can own part of the protocol and like i
said no one has to ask for permission so it's
exploding across the world and i i am excited
to be building alongside people like yourself
who are really passionate as well in sharing the
message because it's important it's important
that it's out there because there's plenty of
people saying dick reminding energy usage is bad
and someone has to tell them it's not and it's
here for the betterment of society absolutely just
one last question then um how religious would
you say bitcoin is and the reason i ask this
is because um so i don't believe i don't
think it's like religious in terms of like
you know a cult or anything like that you know
but i think it's kind of like religious in terms
of like you dedicate your life to an idea an idea
that people should take personal responsibility
people should be free people should be sovereign
and people should be independent um from um
you know government systems and then you sort of
build your life around this you know whether it's
you know your social life probably is your
social life you know dating life work life
you know everything about your life is really
surrounded by this philosophy and this ideology
um so yeah how sort of religious would you
say it is so i think bitcoin is uh religious
in the sense that it it maintains this
pretense of a way that society can function
so it creates this delusion which at the end of
the day becomes a self-fulfilling prophecy of um
a new way of doing business a new way of control
a new belief that this is how it should be
so we're we're basically the dollar and the euro
and these things that we believe in are created
because of a mass hallucination between millions
of individuals that say yes this thing exists
but the dollar it doesn't exist it exists
because it affects our world and it has
momentum and it means something to everyone in the
world we decide to trade our time for that dollar
but if you take away the dollars being worth
anything and that they're just pieces of paper
we are no longer going to trade our time for
that so i believe that bitcoin is the same
way where it is a mass hallucination and the
goal is to get as many people believers into
the hallucination because it's better for them
it's better for society if we run on bitcoin than
if we run on dollars it's like how long do you
think until we're a society that runs on bitcoin
i think we need to clarify that farther i would
say if you can clarify as a society that runs
on bitcoin being 50 of the transactions are
happening in bitcoin uh like 100 years i think
it's gonna take a long time to get there yeah but
that's where we're here and we're building for the
future that you know our kids will experience
in the world i think um i tend to agree but i
think it'd be much faster i mean the reason i
think we're much faster is because life is crazy
right now like we i didn't yeah i didn't interview
with mark moss last week and he was talking about
like peak centralization coming at like 2025
um and i think once that happens that's when
we go on to the bitcoin standard here's why i
disagree with you okay the amount of bonds traded
in u.s dollars is insane trillions of dollars it
makes anything on the bitcoin network look small
so this whole financial system of financialization
of assets in oil and gas and real estate uh
is is massively big and that's what
made me believe that money doesn't exist
that money is a complete hallucination that even
trading your time for a thousand dollars an hour
is still not worth it and you should be
building equity in a business that you own
because the amount of dollars created in
the financials financial markets through
these ways of seasoning debt and doing these
interesting intricate financial transactions make
a day-to-day consumer purchase even a real estate
purchase looks so small look insignificant buying
a half a million dollar home because of the scale
and size of these papers that are being pushed
okay jp um where can people follow you get
involved with your work you know the mining
store how can people get involved sure so you can
reach out to us at sales monitor.com if you're
interested in uh getting mining you can check out
the miningstore.com website you can message me
or check follow me on twitter at jp barrick on
instagram at john paul barrick that's b-a-r-i-c
on tick tock as jp barrick and if you're
looking to work with a great team and help
build the vision you can email us at hiring at
miningstore.com and we're always looking for a
great people to work with sounds amazing well
jp i want to thank you so much it's been so
interesting hearing your perspective on bitcoin
life entrepreneurship um it's the perfect match
for my show so it's really great having you on
thank you so much thanks again i appreciate it
yeah absolutely and guys please don't forget
to hit the subscribe button hit the like button
so you never miss um one of my brilliant
guests and we will see you all next week